this is jocko podcast number 249
with echo charles and me jaco willink
good evening echo good evening
one seal kia is inbound to camp ramadi
kia killed in action
when the call came over the radio from
the army company commander who was
supporting my seals in the field i felt
instantly
nauseous i wanted to throw up
but i knew i had to remain calm i had to
keep my emotions in check
as the commander of seal team 3 tasking
at bruiser
i knew the whole tactical operations
center
and my entire task unit would be
watching my reaction
to this so i took a breath and did my
best
to seem composed and in control
beyond that i wasn't quite sure how to
react
or what to say or what to do
this seal soon reported as
mark allen lee the first seal
killed in iraq
he was shot and killed while assaulting
a building in south central ramadi
on august 2 2006.
a hero
young and full of love
and life and spirit and now in an
instant
gone
seals had been fighting in iraq for more
than three years
at this point there had been some
casualties
but no seals had been killed
and no seal from seal team 3 which was
formed in 1983
had ever been killed in action
while other seals from other teams had
been lost in afghanistan
no one above me and the immediate chain
of command had ever been
in sustained intense combat much less
suffered their men
being killed
though we had drilled the tactical
mechanics of how to react when a man was
lost
we had never trained for how to handle
death from a leadership
perspective no one had ever even
discussed
it with me there was no guidance from my
senior officers on the matter
i had to get my guidance from somewhere
else
so i turned to a man who had offered me
so much valuable advice
about war and about leadership
i turned to colonel david hackworth
and his book about face
in its well-worn pages i found the
council
i needed quote the fact is generally
there's no timeout for mourning on the
battlefield
but it's really no different than the
father of ten who comes home to find his
house on fire
with all of his kids sleeping inside he
doesn't stop and cry over the first
child he finds dead
to do so would be to sign a death
warrant for the other nine
a commanding officer is often in the
same situation
to do anything but continue on
would be complete dereliction of duty
and in the larger picture
could possibly lead to even worse
carnage among his troops
so you do what you have to do and only
later when things settle down
do you allow yourself to grieve end
quote
like i had many times before
i followed the guidance of colonel
hackworth
the battle of ramadi was not going to
stop
there were still missions that needed to
be conducted still enemy that needed to
be killed
i told the task unit that we would do
the only thing we could do
the only thing we should do and the only
thing mark would want us to do
put on our gear lock and load our
weapons
and go back to work do
our duty
the men understood this seemingly harsh
course of action
and that was exactly what we did
everyone accepted this direction from me
not because of my rank or my position
but because they knew something
fundamental about me
that despite my hardened demeanor and my
measured emotions
they knew i cared about them more than
anything else in the world
this feeling came to me instinctively
but it had been reinforced
over and over again by what i had read
in the pages of about-face
colonel hackworth's commitment to his
men was one of the primary reasons i
related to his book
he wrote quote the thing was you had to
look after your soldiers
it was true that a commanding officer's
first priority was the mission
but a conflicting requirement was the
welfare of the men
it was true that the whole purpose of
the military establishment
was to get a doe foot eyeball to eyeball
with the enemy
and it was equally true that the troops
were the ones
who paid the price in blood for an
objective
secured these facts made
and make an infantry commanding officer
a hanging judge
he has incredible power over the lives
and deaths
not only of a faceless enemy but of his
men
that power causes a leader to become
hardened
he stops seeing his troops as human
beings
they become faceless assets to him he
becomes afraid to get close or feel
instead constructing a concrete barrier
in his head
to keep out the guilt and pain of lives
lost at his behest
in the process he forgets that though he
may give the orders
it is the soldier who makes them happen
or doesn't he forgets that if you want
from a trooper you have to give him 200
percent as a commander
end quote that was hackworth's
standard you had to give 200 to your men
you had to give them everything you had
i strived for that standard my whole
career
i had spent my entire adult life in the
seal teams like colonel hackworth
i'd come up through the ranks spending
my first eight years as an enlisted seal
before eventually being selected for a
commissioning program
and becoming a seal officer
i worked hard but that was in the 1990s
there was no war to fight so we trained
and trained and trained even more
when we deployed around the globe we
trained other countries troops
but we didn't fight september 11
2001 changed all that
the war kicked off in afghanistan in
2001 and by 2003
the focus had shifted to iraq
my first combat deployment was as a seal
platoon commander in baghdad
from the autumn of 2003 into the spring
of 2004.
my platoon conducted dynamic direct
action missions and capture killed
scores of enemy personnel
we were also ambushed a few times and
shot at with rpgs
and machine guns we returned fire at
suspected enemy positions or at muzzle
flashes we saw in darkened alleyways
windows or doorways
during that deployment only one seal on
patrol with me was wounded
shot in the head luckily it was just a
ricochet
that had enough energy to puncture his
skin but not enough to puncture his
skull
it left nothing but a minor wound
in the end baghdad felt more like an
exciting adventure for me and my platoon
than a war i returned from that
deployment feeling as if we had done our
share
i even felt some arrogance starting to
creep into my head
as if we had tamed war
but that arrogance was kept in check by
a reminder that lived in another corner
of my mind
yes we had done our job yes we had
executed our missions
yes we had been to war
but it was not the same as the wars i
had read about over the years
being a seal and a professional military
man i had read many books about war
those books reminded me that what we had
been through in baghdad was no
omaha beach or guadalcanal
it wasn't the chosen reservoir or the
inchon landing
it was no idrang valley or battle of way
city
nothing i experienced on my first
deployment to iraq was even close to the
level
of combat detailed in the books i had
read
of course technically what i had been
through was classified as war
but for my seal platoon in baghdad in
2003 and 2004
conducting short and simple operations
with a huge tactical advantage
over a disorganized and untrained enemy
our experience was as forgiving and
benign
as war could be i was lucky
but my next deployment to the capital
city of al-anbar province a city known
as
ramadi was different
when we arrived in the spring of 2006
it was a complete war zone
vehicles mangled by roadside bombs
littered the streets
many buildings were reduced to rubble
and almost every building was pockmarked
with machine gun bullet holes
but the clearest indicator of the level
of violence in ramadi was the casualties
every day american soldiers or marines
were wounded
or killed every single
day i had spent
almost 16 years training and preparing
for this deployment to ramadi
first i had completed the basic seal
training course
known as buds or basic underwater
demolition seal training but that
training was simply a weeding out
process to get rid of the men who didn't
really want
to be there almost no tactical lessons
are learned there
other than to suffer in silence
after buds i went through seal tactical
training or stt
which later became known as sqt or the
seal
qualification training
during that training i began to learn
the individual tactical skills i needed
to perform my duties as a seal
once i completed that training i was
assigned to a seal platoon
where my real learning began
i finally became part of a team where
working together was the only way to
achieve mission success
we learned how to fire and maneuver we
learn the fundamental tactics of
gunfighting
we learn how to conduct ambushes and
raids and assaults on buildings and oil
platforms
and ships at sea
surprisingly unlike in the army or the
marine corps where there are written
instructions on how to do almost
anything
in the seal teams most of what we
learned was not taught from a book or a
field manual
it was passed down by word of mouth just
as it had been for decades
by more experienced platoon members and
the seal
instructor cadre i was lucky enough to
learn from some of the older vietnam era
seals
but by that time the early 90s most of
the vietnam veterans were
gone and with them almost all the real
world combat experience was gone
as well so while the training was good
there were some disconnects between the
simulated training combat we conducted
and what war was actually like
in the 12 years prior to my deployment
to baghdad i had done multiple training
cycles and deployments
and had even served as an instructor
cadre myself
teaching the skills i had learned all
those years of experience prepared me as
well as they could have
from my deployment as a platoon
commander to baghdad
upon my return to america after that
deployment i did another training cycle
to prepare to deploy back to iraq this
time
to ramadi in charge of two seal platoons
that made up
task unit bruiser
surprisingly during all those years of
training
i had received very little leadership
instruction
there was no sealed doctrine about
leadership we attended no
classes on the subject nor did we follow
any specific leadership protocol
we were simply expected to learn it
through ojt
on the job training passed on by word of
mouth
the same way we acquired our bulk of
tactical knowledge
we also learned very little about war
beyond straightforward tactical
knowledge
how to shoot move and communicate inside
a sealed platoon
sure we learned the mechanics of
battlefield maneuvers
but we didn't talk about fear and stress
we didn't learn about the psychological
impact of combat or the emotional shock
of the horrors of war
no one counseled me on the human
capacity for evil
or the human capacity for good
i was never taught about human nature
which is revealed in its rawest form
on the battlefield and while i didn't
know what i didn't know
i could sense there was a gap between
what we learned about
tactics and what i truly needed to know
in order to effectively lead men
into combat i tried to close that gap in
knowledge
by reading i read everything i could get
my hands on about war
but i didn't concentrate on the broad
strategic and political aspects of war
sure i studied why heads of states made
decisions
i read about presidents and prime
ministers and four-star generals and
admirals
but i focus most intently on
first-person accounts
the actual experiences of those
front-line men
who did the fighting than the junior and
non-commissioned officers
who led them the men
storming the beaches assaulting enemy
machine gun nests
and patrolling through jungles laced
with booby traps
what they did how they did it what they
felt
i read and read and read
the authors of these books became my
teachers
at some point and i can't remember
exactly when it was
i stumbled upon a book that changed the
way i thought about war
and leadership and life
in fact it changed the way i thought
about everything
that book was about face by david
hackworth a retired colonel
who had joined the army just after world
war ii was battlefield commissioned
in korea served multiple tours in
vietnam and who became
one of the most highly decorated
soldiers of all time
by the time he retired he was a master
tactician
he understood battlefield terrain he
knew how to maneuver
combat elements on the battlefield but
more important than any of those
accolades
awards and skills colonel david
hackworth
knew people and he knew how to lead
when i take stock of everything that
i've learned in my life about war
about strategy and tactics about human
nature and about leadership
it is colonel hackworth's book that is
the clear
wellspring for so much of that knowledge
and of all the warriors heroes and
leaders who i have known and who have
mentored me over the years
it is this man colonel david hackworth a
man whom i've never met
that provided me with the most guidance
and was always there
to coach train mentor me through the
words he wrote
in about face i read this book
at every opportunity during the battle
of ramadi
in its pages i found the instruction i
needed
it was next to my cot in camp and if i
wasn't in the field
the end of every day was spent learning
from this book i could open the book to
any section
read a few pages and relate what i read
to what i was living
leadership in the harshest environment
without question
my leadership style my tactical
knowledge the decisions i've made
and my view of the world has been shaped
through the lens of this book
colonel hackworth did not only affect my
life and career in the military
after leaving the navy i started a
leadership consulting company
have authored many books of my own speak
regularly about leadership
have a popular leadership podcast and
continue to
teach leadership let there be no doubt
everything i've written and all the
leadership lessons i espouse
are all rooted in about face
what makes that fact even more
interesting is that about face is not
meant to be a
leadership book it was not written
for the purpose of teaching leadership
it is an autobiography
it simply tells the story of colonel
hackworth's life
and experiences but wrapped in that
story
and those experiences is a complete
manifesto
on leadership and human nature
but even with all those powerful lessons
to teach colonel hackworth
was not always the easiest mentor to
follow
when i first started to speak of him to
fellow service members
he was not viewed in a universally
positive way
in the navy among many senior officers
that i encountered
colonel hackworth was viewed with a
strong sense of disdain
in 1996 hackworth wrote an article about
then chief of naval operations admiral j
borda
charging the admiral with wearing a
medal on his uniform
that he did not rate a navy combination
medal
with the combat distinguishing device
also known as the combat v
the combat v is awarded only when there
is direct
combat with the enemy while admiral
borta did serve honorably
aboard a u.s navy warship during the
vietnam war
he was never in direct combat when
admiral borda committed suicide
in the aftermath of the investigation
some blamed colonel hackworth
for the admiral's death while i
understood the grief around the
admiral's death i also saw
hackworth's perspective for colonel
hackworth
the combat infantryman was sacred
he had watched men on the front line
serve and sacrifice
life and limb in two wars
to colonel hackworth the admiral wearing
an award he did not merit
was an affront to every man that had
ever seen close combat with the enemy
hackworth could not and would not let
that stand
but the fallout from the article colonel
hackworth wrote
left a small tribe of senior naval
officers with a strong aversion to
hackworth
and his perspectives some
army leadership also disliked hackworth
and disparaged him when i brought up his
name
while they wouldn't quite call him a
turncoat some army soldiers viewed the
end of hackworth's career
in the service and his subsequent
participation in the anti-nuclear
movement a slap in the face of the u.s
army
the u.s military and america
his parting shot while on active duty
was an interview with
abc news correspondent howard tucker for
the show
issues and answers in which colonel
hackworth skewered much of the civilian
and military leadership
their understanding of strategy and
tactics and their gross misconduct of
the war
he bluntly put the blood of american
servicemen
on the senior leader's hands quote i
don't feel that too many division
commanders
or even separate brigade commanders
really understood the name of the game
he said did you
did this mean more us casualties this
misunderstanding of the name of the game
as you put it mr tucker asked
absolutely absolutely hackworth
responded
it is easy for many to see this as
insubordination
to view hackworth as a rebellious
mutineer trying to denigrate the
military system
but i saw something different i saw a
man who had dedicated his entire life to
the service of his country
and to his army a man who cared deeply
about the men in his charge
and every man who wore the cloth of the
nation a man who had seen too many of
those men
fed into the meat grinder that was the
war in vietnam
and for what he failed to see any
progress in the vietnam war and he
failed to see any way to achieve victory
as long as the military continued with
the same ineffective strategies and
tactics
he could not stand to watch the
suffering and needless death
anymore it wasn't at all that he hated
the army
the military or the country it was that
he loved them all
too much so he spoke the truth
but the sting of this interview and of
his attitude after he was shuffled out
of the army left the mark
a mark of resentment that was passed on
to the army and the military
and a resentment that was alive and well
when i discovered hackworth
and about face so it was not always a
pleasant task
to carry the flag and be a follower of
hackworth
fortunately hackworth's lessons stand
the test of time against any naysayer
and this book is absolutely filled with
his lessons
but the lessons are not only about war
while the subtitle of about-face is the
odyssey of an american warrior
it could also be aptly subtitled
comprehensive lessons in leadership
battlefield tactics strategy command and
control
and the essence of human nature
well it might seem impossible that any
book could contain so much knowledge
about face does just that
every page is dense with lessons that
provide guidance on leadership
combat human interaction and just about
every other aspect of life
and i followed that guidance in fact
i often say that much of what i learned
and teach as a leader
i stole from colonel hackworth when
hackworth
took over fox company in korea
he immediately changed its name from fox
company to fighter company
quote fox company was dead i told them
from this moment on we were fighter the
troops got a charge out of it
end quote he did the same thing as a
battalion commander in vietnam
when he took command of the 439th
battalion
it had no unit identity he promptly
changed its name
to the hardcore and began to call the
troops
recondos i followed his example
when i became a task unit commander at
seal team 3 in the spring of 2005
my task unit was assigned the generic
title bravo
a name simply taken from the phonetic
alphabet
to designate us as the second of three
task units at seal team three
the other two being alpha and charlie
in our first meeting as a task unit i
let everyone know that we were no longer
task unit bravo
we were task unit bruiser
i saw faces change almost before my eyes
as we began to take on the personality
of our namesake like colonel hackworth
had taught me
the troops got a charge out of it
i also knew that colonel hackworth had a
methodology around building
relationships
he knew that too much familiarity out of
the gate
with the troops could cause problems in
the chain of command
he ensured that the first impression he
made with new men
was that the mission and the business of
soldiering and leading
was paramount so he showed no signs of
friendliness when he first met his
troops
quote for the first month i was with the
unit i refused to crack a smile
said hackworth of joining his battalion
in vietnam
i did the same thing with task unit
bruiser there were no smiles from me
when we first formed up
the men knew from the beginning that the
business of war
came first these were some of the
these were some of the countless
leadership techniques
i took from colonel hackworth hackworth
was also a champion of discipline
he kept his uniform squared away and
wore a high and tight haircut
i always kept my dress uniforms pristine
and my hair inspection ready
colonel hackworth was an avid supporter
of snipers
he invested heavily in them in his
battalion in vietnam and
understood their impact i did the same
thing in ramadi
utilizing our seal snipers to flip the
script
and turn my troops into the hunters
instead of the hunted
i also followed his lead when it came to
training troops
quote i wanted each unit trained so well
that a pfc could take a platoon and run
it wrote colonel hackworth
about training i strive for the same
goal
and i often had my junior men run
training operations
he also wrote quote i'd have one platoon
aggress against
another and then reverse them until they
were masters of both
attack and defense procedures end quote
in the seal teams we called this a force
on force training
and because of hackworth i made that
type of training paramount for my troops
in my final years in the seal teams i
codified the essential elements of what
i'd learned into what i
ended up calling the laws of combat
cover and move
simple prioritize and execute and
decentralize command
those four laws became part of the seal
leadership
doctrine they also became the basis of
the principles i teach to leaders in
business and other organizations around
the world
those principles are all rooted in
lessons i learned
from about face
the first law of combat is cover and
move in a gunfight this means
one person or squad or platoon shooting
at the enemy to keep the enemy's heads
down
which is known as suppressive fire so
the other person or squad or platoon can
maneuver
hackworth cites this principle again and
again
with statements like quote while the
others laid down a good base of fire
or tying down the enemy while providing
a base of fire
and one man providing covering fires the
other edge close enough to flip in a
frag
statements like that repeated throughout
about-face made me realize that the
number
one law of combat was that people have
to cover and move for one another
to be alone on the battlefield was to
die alone
but this law does not only apply to the
battlefield it applies to
any team or organization teams have to
work together to support one another
cover and move means teamwork and it is
critical for the success
of any team the second law of combat is
simple
plans must be simple and straightforward
so that every person
on the team understands the plan and
knows how to execute it
simple plans will also hold up under the
chaos
and stress of combat complex plans will
fall apart
colonel hackworth believed in keeping
things simple while planning a mission
to destroy an enemy supply depot that
consisted of caves
deep behind enemy lines that heavy
artillery and air power failed to
eliminate
colonel hackworth knew keeping things
simple was a necessity
quote during an aerial recon i found the
simplest way to make the raid
we'd wade up the center of that creek it
would cover any noise
and simplify navigation end quote
not only do plans need to be simple but
communication needs to be simple as well
if a leader gives direction in
complicated and convoluted language
the direction will not be understood
simple clear concise language is
required so team members understand
colonel hackworth knew this while
preparing to lead an operation into
vietnam's mountainous highland terrain
he knew it would be disastrous for his
men to carry too much gear and equipment
so he let the men know what was most
important
quote the single order was a simple one
lighten up end quote
keeping things simple is an age-old
military maxim that applies to any
organization in any arena
colonel hackworth knew this to be the
truth
keep it simple
the third law of combat is prioritize
and execute
there will be multiple problems on the
battlefield
if a leader tries to solve all those
problems at once his resources will be
spread
too thin and he will fail at solving any
of them
so a leader has to prioritize what the
biggest problem is
and then execute on solving that problem
first before moving on to the next
biggest problem
one of the most obvious examples of this
is tending to wounded men
as colonel hackworth advises quote in a
hot fire fight
a rifle platoon can take 10 casualties
before you can cry medic
and if you multiply by 10 the one
rifleman who falls out to look after his
buddy
suddenly you've lost the guts of the
platoon's firepower
a leader cannot give the enemy the
initiative
by allowing his unit to become
ineffective as a result of care for the
wounded becoming the first
priority any other course carried
not only the risk of failure to
accomplish the mission
but also the loss of a hell of a lot
more men than necessary
end quote the idea of prioritize and
execute
does not only apply to the battlefield
it also applies to business
and life taking on too many projects or
trying to multitask
across a wide number of undertakings
simultaneously
will result in failure leaders cannot
allow that to happen
instead a leader must do as colonel
hackworth did
prioritize and execute
the last law of combat is decentralized
command allowing subordinate leaders to
lead
this is fundamental to the success of
any military unit or team
subordinate leaders need to understand
the mission the goal
the end state the parameters they are
allowed to work within what the overall
intent of the mission is
and most important why they are doing
what they are doing
then they have to be given the authority
and the autonomy to go and execute
a failure to work with this mentality is
disastrous
as hackworth explains in about face
quote
in this the third year of the war
whether or not
to hold a pimple of a hill became an
issue for the eighth army
the pentagon and sometimes the president
the only problem was that while those
guys hemmed and hawed over whether to
withdraw or reinforce
down at the cutting edge american
soldiers died
it would become known as centralization
end quote centralization does not work
not on the battlefield not in business
not in life
leaders cannot hold the reins of command
too tight
leaders have to let their people lead
these were not the only lessons i
learned from colonel hackworth
he taught me about discipline and fear
building relationships
playing the game when to break the rules
the list goes on and on
colonel hackworth also taught me about
things that i shouldn't do
from areas where he fell short
sometimes he lost his temper or let his
ego drive his actions
sometimes he lashed out at people when
he should have kept his mouth shut
sometimes he broke rules that he
shouldn't have broken
his family life while he was on active
duty was less than ideal
but even when colonel hackworth wasn't
right he was humble and honest about it
which meant i could still learn from him
even in his mistakes
he mentored me over time
although i knew he wasn't perfect i put
colonel hackworth
on a pedestal but as he taught me
i was always questioning both myself and
others
i didn't want to fall victim to what he
said in about-face
was among the biggest mistakes of the
war which was that quote
politicians only listen to these
generals and these generals
only listen to themselves end quote so i
always wondered
what the people who actually knew and
worked with colonel hackworth
really thought of him i was lucky to be
able to have that question
answered when i had the honor of
interviewing retired brigadier general
james h mukayama for an episode of my
podcast
general mukayama had an incredible
career one of the highlights of which
was serving as a company commander for
colonel hackworth in vietnam
this was my chance to find out if
colonel hackworth
deserved the reverence and respect i
felt for him
general mukayama had been a young
captain when colonel hackworth reported
to fort lewis washington
as a new battalion commander i
asked the general if he knew who colonel
hackworth was before he met him
general mukayama replied quote of course
we all knew hack was a legend
everybody knew who he was he was mr
infantry end quote i asked how
everybody knew of colonel hackworth
general mukayama explained
quote it wasn't only his reputation it
was his appearance
his neck was the size of my waist his
hair was an eighth of an inch
razor sharp sides and all that it was
the way he carried himself
his philosophy was that you were either
a dud or a stud
and there was nothing in between when he
came to a unit and found
some guys that weren't cutting it they
were gone
especially in combat end quote
general mukayama also told me that
colonel hackworth
quote never did things for personal gain
he always did things for the unit
and for the soldiers end quote
for the soldiers
it is that underlying theme that
permeates about face
and is that underlying theme that stuck
with me
as a leader but people's strengths
are often their weaknesses and perhaps
doing things
for the soldiers was colonel hackworth's
undoing
in his interview with issues and answers
when howard tucker
asked if he had become too emotionally
involved in vietnam
he responded quote one couldn't see the
number of young
studs die or be terribly wounded without
becoming emotionally involved
i just have seen the american nation
spend so much of its wonderful
great young men in this country i've
seen our national wealth being drained
away i see the nation being split apart
and almost being split asunder because
of this war and i'm wondering
to what end it is all going to lead
end quote
from that emotional feeling about the
cost of war came colonel hackworth's
metaphorical
about face his turn away from the war
away from the army
and away from america
but he could not turn his back forever
his heart was too connected his soul too
caring
that's why colonel david hackworth wrote
this book
and it's why he dedicated it quote
to all the dough boys the ground
pounders
the grunts the american infantrymen
past present
and especially future end quote
well hack if i may be so
presumptuous as to call you what your
friends called you
your dedication has hit home
and your lessons have not been forgotten
this book captures the lessons you
learned in blood
and passes them on i
use them on the battlefield with my
seals as we served alongside
soldiers and marines in fierce fighting
during the battle of ramadi
i passed them on to the next generation
of seals when i ran training for seal
platoons
and troops deploying to iraq and
afghanistan
i have talked about them at our service
academies and i've shared them with
leaders and future leaders
at every level and in every branch of
the military
your service to the infantrymen carries
on
but i will also tell you hack that your
impact does not stop at your cherished
infantrymen your leadership philosophies
strategies and tactics can be applied by
any leader
at any level in any situation just as
you found when you applied them to the
civilian world yourself
and ran highly profitable and successful
businesses i've taught your principles
to countless civilian leaders
in every industry imaginable and have
seen them applied over and over again
with extraordinary outcomes
so thank you hack
thank you for writing this book thank
you for being my mentor
thank you for your service and sacrifice
to our great nation
and even now that you have passed
thank you for taking care of your
beloved soldiers
we will follow your lead
jocko willing january
2020.
and that is
the forward for a
new release of the book about face which
is
now available
and obviously it was just
an absolute honor to be able to write
this thing and it's
it seems it seems i know this word might
be a little bit much
it seems a little bit surreal yeah you
know to have had this book had this huge
impact on me and then to be able to
to be able to write the forward is just
to have my name on this book with
you know this guy that has had this
massive influence on me
is crazy yeah it's surreal for me
and i'm me the yeah when you like what
episode was that when you first
covered that book this is the first book
we covered on the podcast it's episode
two
episode one of this podcast was uh
hey this is what we're doing and answer
some questions episode two is about face
yeah and i knew that i mean when we
started episode one i already knew we
were
i knew what we were doing next so and
that's kind of what happened
so what happened was i i first
mentioned the book when i was on tim
ferriss's podcast which was the first
interview i ever did
and no one had any idea who i would
why why would they know who i was or
whatever
but he asked that he asked you know he
asks
asks the same bulk of questions most of
the time and so
one of the questions that he asks is
what's the book that you've
most gifted and for me
there's not a that's a very easy
question because you know i don't first
of all give many gifts
but second of all i'd only ever given
anyone any book ever
and it was this book i gave actually i
gave a copy to leif i gave a
copy to seth stone that's who got this
book
so that was pretty easy and so i kind of
mentioned it there and
you know maybe some people got their
interests peaked about the book then
but then we started the podcast this
podcast a couple months later
and this was the first book we covered
and then of course i refer to it all the
time
not only on this podcast but you know
someone else will ask me that question
pretty common question right like what's
what's a great book
or what book yeah and so through all
this
through all these mentions of the book
and talking about the book it started to
sell
so the book the original book came out
in 1989 yeah
so it started to sell and it actually
started to sell a lot
like a lot of copies which doesn't
happen there's very few books that
basically get brought back from the dead
right
when a book's over it's over and it's
outdated and they're moving on to the
next book
so it's very seldom that they have and
there's some name for it i don't know in
the publishing world
there's a name for for what happens
if a book basically rises from the dead
and so the publishers
you know having to reprint these books
and they're kind of they're stoked
obviously
because they're just making money now
and someone in their department you know
in whatever they have a department say
it's like archived books or so there's
some name for these type of old books
if they come back and so someone started
pulling the string and doing the
research and trying to figure out
where this was all coming from why
they're selling this book that hasn't
sold in
you know in 30 years or close to 40
years 35 years it hasn't you know
hasn't been a huge seller it was a new
york times bestseller when it came out
but you know you get you
that doesn't normally happen that they
come back so they
pulled the string on it and investigated
and eventually
found me and said hey you know we're
we're going to reissue this book would
you like to do a blurb
for the back meaning a little quote on
the back of the book saying you know
something this is a great book
and me being
give me an inch and i'm going to try and
take a mile i said never mind
a blurb i said i'll write a full forward
for this thing
and they were all stoked about it and so
so here it is the book is out the new
version of about face
by colonel david hackworth forward by
jacob willink that's me
that's crazy yeah that is so you know
like i'll do this
thing where you kind of kind of go back
in time
in a way it's not like remembering a
certain time it's not just remembering
but it's remembering
and then also remembering your mindset
and how you were thinking and what
you're kind of feeling
generally in that time frame you know
kind of thing
your values and all that you kind of put
yourself in that exact mindset as you
were back then right so it's like one of
these things where
you think back to episode two
one whenever even before that and how it
was
it's such this massive part of your way
and
you know your favorite book all this
stuff and then to think
back then now yeah in a few years i'm
going to be writing the forward to a
re-release of this book right here it's
like that part kind of makes it surreal
even for like me you know
it's crazy you know it was uh you know
jordan peterson
and i talked to him about this because
he wrote a new forward
of the re-release of the gulag
archipelago
and same thing that was kind of a dead
book
and all of a sudden you know this
popular guy comes and starts talking
about it and then they re-released it
and who wrote the forward
and so i talked to jordan about it you
know i said i said hey how was that
process and
it but it's probably pretty similar
feeling for him you know of this book
that he
really he he got a lot of his
thought from this book and then they
re-release it and he wrote the forward
and so when i talked about i was kind of
telling him the same thing about what
was going on
so i think we had a similar level of
stoke
yeah clearly on that but you know we
talked about it we talked about on
episode two
we talked about it with when when uh jim
mukayama
general mukayama was on mook
coolest guy when he was on and i read
all the sections you know that he was
kind of involved in and
that was awesome but i i wanted to cover
some more of the book right now and look
the book is massive you know it's 800
and something pages
so it's a big book
but i wanted to read a little bit more
of it
just because look i haven't read i just
spent whatever 40 minutes reading my
words
but my words pale in comparison
to the man himself
[Laughter]
so here we go let's jump into the book
about face
6 february 1951 when i first saw them
about a thousand yards to our front
the enemy looked like little black ants
racing from the village towards
snow-covered hills it was clear
cloudless morning
the temperature hovered around zero as
the tanks kept rolling
closing on the ants and the hills set
astride
the road dead ahead
my squad was piggyback on the lead tank
fighting in this frigid temperature
is think about it you're trying to
manipulate your weapon
anytime you stop you're freezing
i don't know i like the cold better than
the heat you know what i'm saying
yeah you probably like the heat better
than the cold i don't know
under circum certain circumstances yeah
and no ben i remember at uh we jump in
the ice bath right for like i don't know
20 minutes you go your whole body
whatever when you get out of there yeah
you can't move
like you can't move your fingers like to
do yeah you can't do that kind of stuff
so i don't know man the heat kind of
i mean if you have water but you don't
always have water apparently yeah
i don't know man that's pretty pretty
jammed up i don't yeah that's a good
point the good point is
it's either way it sucks but certainly
the cold is gonna suck
i was my back to the book my squid squad
was writing piggyback on the lead tank
it was no long
it was no honor being first
in the grim parade we'd already ravaged
the tank's toolbox and knocked off some
rations to eat on the way
and now our only comfort was the motor
of the m46 which
belt some welcome heat over our near
frozen bodies
there you go how you going to stay warm
just get by tank
exhaust fumes
the tank commander relayed lieutenant
lands order to dismount
i got the guys off like a shot and hit
the ground running as the tank rolled on
beside us
when i looked beside me when i looked
behind me i saw the rest of third
platoon had not dismounted
maybe i'd heard wrong maybe i was just
overeager
but it's damn near impossible for
infantry men to reboard a moving tank so
there was no choice but to keep running
and hope i hadn't blown it too badly
with the lieutenant
i didn't see the ants again for what
seemed like a lifetime
but i sure as hell knew where they were
in an instant the familiar roar of the
tanks was drowned out
by the deafening sound of incoming
machine gun mortar artillery
and self-propelled anti-tank at fire
like a buzz saw the deadly crossfire was
cutting into my platoon
there was at least a dozen enemy machine
guns on the high ground
and on both sides of the road
high ground it's like all these when i
read these things
all these little things they just they
just
seeped into my mind over time
high ground hi like this is that that
word is just in this book oh high ground
high ground oh they got the high ground
we got the high ground my guys still
running alongside our maneuvering tank
were totally shielded the other squads
on the exposed decks of their tanks were
hit hard by the time we made it to the
side of the rice paddy wall
and set up a base of fire most of what
was left the third platoon was scattered
across the frozen ground
the tanks pulled off the road and rolled
into position online
once there they froze
earlier in the assembly area a tank
commander had told me as unit
the 64th tank battalion hadn't seen much
hard combat
i believed him as soon as they were
fired upon
these tankers became paralyzed they
plumb forgot
all their training and just sat there in
those great big armored holes
while the enemy went on throwing
everything at us but the mess hall
walk i jumped on the back of the platoon
leader's tank and thumped on the hatch
with the butt of my rifle the lieutenant
opened the hatch a crack
hey lieutenant i yelled get some fire
going
at the enemy get the big gun going get
the machine guns going
what's he asking for right there he's
asking for cover fire like we're stuck
you got a freaking tank open fire
the lieutenant was not with it it seemed
as though he had no comprehension of the
fix we were in
slugs were splatting hard on the side of
the tank the self-propelled
at fire which was screaming down the
valley dug
deep furrows all around us and yet the
tanks
still sat there silently like big fat
clay ducks at a shooting gallery
sergeant
the lieutenant finally said in a
shell-shocked kind of days
look look you see out there on the ice
yes i saw it it was a pile cap a little
fur ball on the ice amid my platoon's
dead and wounded the bullets and the
blood
that's my cap he said would you get it
from me
so you know what what are you learning
from that right there you are learning
that people
are not going to be able to handle
certain situations and they might be
focused on something that they shouldn't
be focused on
i mean and this is an extreme example
but
if you've never been to combat before
and you're in a leadership position you
might need to
learn a lesson from that that you might
get guys that aren't going to
act the way you would expect them to act
what does he do back to the book i
considered shooting the sorry son of a
[ __ ] then and there
climbing inside his tank and taking
command fortunately
reason prevailed i grabbed him and shook
him until he looked as if he was back to
the real world
then i instructed him to have three
tanks concentrate on the self-propelled
at fire to our front
and use the others to start placing main
gun fire on the hills
to give him a bit of encouragement i
manned the tank's 50
turret gun and blasted one of the hills
myself until i'd used up all the ammo
and the commander got his men into
action
what does that tell you what do you do
when people aren't do that's a lead from
the front scenario
you know in leadership strategy and
tactics i went through this whole
the book the book leadership strategy
and tactics i went through this whole
section talking about leading from the
rear and how you know you want to let
yours
you want to let your leaders lead you
want to let your subordinates lead you
want to let them step up if
if you're always leading from the front
they're they're always following and you
don't want that
but i also make a case for hey there are
absolutely times when you've got a
lead from the front this is one of those
times
once the night back to the book once the
90 millimeter guns got going
we were on our way to gaining fire
superiority
the amount of incoming decreased as the
tankers started to remember why they
were there
but the tank commanders stayed buttoned
up inside their turrets
no one was using the 50 calibers so to
explain this a little bit you know a
tank has like the big gun that you think
of a tank
yeah but then on top of it they have a
machine gun a 50 caliber machine gun
which is a big
giant machine gun and basically you sit
up out of the turret of the tank so
you're exposed but then you can shoot
that 50 cal
wherever you want to shoot it and all
these guys were buttoned up inside their
tanks
not using that weapon now they also have
a weapon usually
that's a machine gun that's coordinated
it's called a coaxial
gun so it's a machine gun so you got the
big main gun which
you know is what you think of when you
see a tank but next to that
is a coaxial machine gun that they can
fire from inside the tank
and it's just a machine gun that's
pointing in the same direction as that
big gun
but then in addition to that they have
this 50 caliber turret mounted gun that
you can
get up out of the web out of the tank
and you can shoot from is that a common
thing
the 50 cal yes huh yeah it's weird i
i never i don't know if i didn't notice
it or what not that i'm
sitting around looking at tanks all the
time nothing but huh
yep so you got three guns on a tank
essentially yeah
i've seen main gun mike my main gun mike
bima yeah
he's a he's a a tank fanatic
sure but but you know he uh he
used all those weapons the coaxial
machine gun his main gun and
his turret mounted 50 cal get some so
what is there two
so three guys in the tank or what
they're like oh i don't know i forget
how many people are in the tank there's
a driver
there's a gunner i want to say there's
three or four people in there huh
interesting yeah it's tight quarters
it's hot
god bless them
so back to the book once the 90
millimeter guns got going we were
on our way to gaining fire superiority
the amount of incoming decreased as this
tanker starting to remember why they
were there
but the tank commanders stayed buttoned
up inside their turrets
no one was using their 50 calibers i
just couldn't believe it
eight inches of steel between them and
the chaos outside
yet they didn't have it in them to help
the sun come out for the guys stopping
slugs with their field jackets
i went from tank to tank pounding on the
hatches and blasting away on each of
their 50s
until all the ammo was exhausted
the this little exercise had its effect
the tank commanders got the word and
started doing what they should have been
doing all along when
no further spoon feeding was required i
returned to my platoon so again that's
just
taking action letting people see you
have to lead from the front sometimes
lesson learned
there were dead and wounded everywhere
slugs were ricocheting
off the ice we could see sparks where
they hit
jim parker's second platoon had
successfully silenced an enemy machine
gun to our left
so the pressure was off us
so the pressure was off enough for us to
get our wounded behind the protection of
the tanks and paddy walls
where they could be patched up our
progress was hampered though
because the tank crews kept moving their
tanks they didn't stop to think they
were exposing our wounded all over again
they were too busy trying to save their
own
armor-coated skins i told the tank
lieutenant
whom i'd come to view and treat
accordingly as a recruit at fort knox
that the next time a tank moved and
exposed our guys i'd fire a 3.5 bazooka
right up his ass
there was no more movement i saw a
soldier prone on the ice
he'd been there a long time i thought he
was dead
but then i saw a movement and rushed out
to get him
my god i thought it's deboer
private henry c deboer had been with
george company since
early in the war he was one of the few
survivors
from the original third platoon
basically because in those first hard
months of
combat he had not seen one good fire
fight he had an uncanny sixth sense
he could always tell when the platoon
was in for a major bloodletting
and invariably he'd find an excuse to be
somewhere else
normally that excuse was going on sick
call which by regulation he was allowed
to do
and you couldn't stop him even though
you knew the only thing that was wrong
with him
was a chronic case of cowardice
deboer himself even admitted he was a
coward
and we hated him for it he was an
outcast from the platoon
and we even had a little song about him
which we'd all sing in unison
quote out of the dark dreary korean
countryside comes the call of the debut
bird
sick call sick call sick call end quote
he pulled this stunt only yesterday as
we were saddling up for this very
operation
he'd sensed the bloodletting all right
but hen figured that the foggy overcast
covering the battlefield would not lift
then the attack would be postponed
he'd returned from the dock last night
with a clean bill of health
most surprised to see us the rest of the
platoon
took great pleasure in the fact that his
malingering little ass
would be in the thick of things in the
morning
now dabur was ashen-faced hit in the
chest or gut
i didn't know there was a lot of blood
and well into shock
i knew he wasn't going to make it come
on deboer
you're going to be fine you'll be all
right i said
giving him the old pep talk as i grabbed
his
jacket collar and started sliding him
across the ice but tabooer said
no sarge just leave me you're gonna get
hit
just leave me sarge then suddenly he
groaned
sarge i just [ __ ] my pants
and that was it he was gone
i left him and ran back
the debuter in death became one of the
great heroes of our outfit
it was true he'd never been anything in
his army life but a coward
but he died right he died like a man
he didn't say take care of me he said
leave me
take care of yourself
and when i told the other guys the story
old deburr
became a legend in the platoon
you know when i whenever i read things
like this you know
or not whenever but sometimes i just
kind of get curious
so you google the internet
interwebs and you know you you
you do do google henry c deboer and
there it is
korean war 6 february 1951
uh from newport news virginia son of
margaret de boer
didn't find much else besides that but
story behind every one of those names
back to the book the road ran north
south and we were on the east side of it
the balance of g
company was on attack maneuvering to
secure the high ground
to the north and to the west there it is
again high ground
do you think that we're in where we've
read four pages
we're talking about high ground do you
think that might be an important thing
in the world
my platoon or what was left of it was
the
fixum element trying to tie down the
enemy while providing a base of fire for
parker's and gilchrist
what does that mean it means cover and
move means he's in the cover position
the other elements are moving
maybe that's important do you think it
is you've never been in combat before
and you hear this guy keep saying put
down cover fire
yes after we got organized i had a
moment to look around i saw my platoon
leader lieutenant land sort of crouched
down leaning against a rice paddy wall
observing the whole action john land was
a good man
a world war ii vet and former g company
nco
he was one of the few battlefield
commissions in the 27th
isn't he a cool customer i thought to
myself now just watching this whole
thing and taking it all
in because really that was about the
only thing you could do in a time like
this
stay cool stay down and establish
fire superiority as best you could do
you think that's an important lesson
to stay cool stay calm stay down get
fire superiority
i examined what we had left in terms of
a fighting force tennessee mitchell
robert delbert bell and old debour
there were seven dead all together and
about a dozen wounded the platoon
sergeant was gone and the assistant
platoon sergeant was nowhere in sight
it seemed that all was left of third
platoon was the balance of my squad bits
and pieces of the other two
and the light machine gun team i ran
over to the lieutenant
to ask for instructions when i got there
i realized the reason lieutenant land
was so cool
was that he was also dead he'd caught a
slug right between the eyes
the blood had poured down his face and
chest filled up the eyepieces of his
binoculars
and frozen there i took the binoculars
and slipped the radio from his dead
radio operators back
i called captain mike lee our company
commander and gave him the situation
report
he said i was now in charge that we were
to continue tying down the enemy
and get the wounded out in that order of
priority
isn't that interesting you've got
the leader giving you two things to do
and telling you that one of them is the
priority
lieutenant gilchrest's first platoon was
having a hell of a time
their attack was being held up by fire
from a hornet's nest of well-concealed
enemy automatic weapons position
just as we'd gotten the wounded under
control one of our guys who'd been doing
some scouting spotted north korean
fighting positions on the other side of
the dike
first platoon was attacking he motioned
me over to have a look
sure enough at least a platoon was dug
in there
almost in the shadow of the tanks they
were so close to the tanks main guns
couldn't depress low enough to hit them
not
nor could their anti-tank weapons hit
our tanks it was a mexican standoff
but not for long so you have tanks
they can only lower their weapons so
much
and so you've got the enemy so close and
in a depressed position
that you can't even shoot them
so you got a little mexican standoff and
then
all right who's going with me i asked so
what is
what is what does hackworth do he
gets default aggressive he's gonna take
action
he's gonna take action uh so he says all
right who's going with me i will said
van meter our platoon medic a stud of a
guy who had a great reputation as a
fighter
as he did as an as a dock while the
others laid down a good base of fire
the dock and i threw two frag grenades
over the dike
hmm what is that that's covered move you
lay down fire
i'm gonna huck grenades
when they exploded we leaped through the
smoke landing front and center of the
enemy
it was eyeballed to eyeball the two of
us facing at least 30 dazed wounded or
dead communists
the enemy appeared to be leaderless they
were certainly in a state of shock
and we cleaned them up and we cleaned up
the position with ease
using rifles and bayonets
you don't think too much of about
bayonet fighting in the korean war but
apparently you're getting after it the
two more
then two more enemy soldiers appeared
out of the smoking confusion dragging a
57 caliber
anti-tank buffalo gun we were no more
than 10 feet apart
i leveled my m1 was about to shoot them
when i looked down and saw that the bolt
was back
my weapon was empty and it wasn't
exactly the time for reloading
i lunged forward with the bayonet at on
guard shouting
tauzong the enemy threw up their hands
the chinese word for surrender was
probably the only one i knew
i'd filed it away in my brain when we
were up north
i must admit it learned i must admit i
learned it thinking that someone would
be saying it to me
but it didn't matter now there they
stood with burp guns still hanging
around their necks a buffalo gun at
their feet and me with an empty rifle
the funny thing was that these guys were
korean not chinese
and the chances that they had understood
what i had said
and the chances and the chances where
they hadn't understood what i had said
anyway
on the other hand in combination with
that long razor sharp bayonet pointed at
them
they probably would have surrendered if
i had given the order in swahili
in any event we took their weapons and
turned the pows over to our men
on the other side of the dike then the
doc and i continued mopping up
in numbers and in firepower these guys
certainly should have outgunned what was
left of third platoon
from the number of bodies buffalo guns
and other 80 weapons we found we
conclude that we'd knocked off an
anti-tank platoon that had been as green
as scared
as our tankers the only difference was
of course that these
north koreans would never tell the story
of their baptism of fire
by the time we rejoined the platoon my
guys had alluded to the two prisoners
the only real treasure was a us-made
waltham pocket
watch which the guys gave to me it
became my sixth february
souvenir none of us spoke korean so i
asked pfc charles to take the pows back
to captain mikely for interrogation
i was really pleased we nailed him
prisoners
are the best source of battlefield
information
pretty pertinent fact
and with the fighting still going
on full tilt all around us it'd be
useful to find out what the hell was
happening in the enemy camp
the first and second platoons of george
were fighting hard to take the high
ground navy corsairs were working with
the enemy over
working the enemy over with napalm and
strafing runs cut off between mine and
gilchrist platoon were an enemy
who'd been bypassed so i took a half a
dozen of our guys and went up the hill
to do some hunting
once again taking action taking the high
ground
the north koreans were cleverly
concealed
well dug bunkers stuffed with straw for
warmth
the pine covered hill was a maze of
seemingly unrelated positions which we
slowly worked through in two man teams
fire in the hole we shouted again and
again
as we grenaded bunker after bunker one
man providing cover fire as the other
edged close enough to flip in a frag hmm
laws of combat move
the enemy did not fight back they stayed
in the bottom of their holes
looking like trapped moles it didn't
take long before we ran out of frag
grenades
a field expedient was quickly devised we
stripped our
tracer slugs from the machine gun belt
and clipped them
for our m1s with one man covering his
partner would slip up to the hole and
snap
off a tray tracer or two into the
position the red-hot slugs would ignite
the straw inside
and when the defender came up coughing
he'd be shot between the horns
gary cooper wiped out a dozen dozens of
german soldiers in
sergeant york by luring them out with a
turkey call
if it was good enough for sergeant york
in hollywood it was good enough for us
on 6 february 1951 we moved from hold a
hole systematically burning the enemy
out until the hilltop above us
suddenly exploded with gunfire the reds
were counter-attacking
as gilchrist platoon fought them off
only six feet from the crest of the hill
we beat feet back to the safety of our
rice paddy wall
patty walls whose purpose in more
peaceful times was
irrigation control where dirt walls
about a foot
thick and about three feet high perfect
cover
for most direct fire weapons infantry
men love them
now leaning against my safe paddy wall
even his first platoon fought off
another counterattack with the help of
second
which could observe the forward slope of
gilchrist hill and provide warning of
the enemy's intention
i realized i was starving i opened a can
of c
rations with my trusty p-38 and dug
right in i started at the top of the can
big
chunks of congealed fat under which lay
beef and potatoes
frozen rock hard about this time an
enemy sniper started firing along the
top of the rice paddy wall
it was harassing fire only no one got
hurt but it got
on all of our nerves far more even than
the largest
battle still going on around us i just
gotten down to the meat
and was about to take my first bite when
zip
a slug creased the furrow in the top of
the wall
right above my head and showered my
rations with debris
i scooped it out i was about to try
another bite win zip another slug
same place did the same thing by the
third time that was it
i was pissed off i'm going to get that
sniper who's with me
ray wells an ace machine gunner and good
old country boy from west virginia
volunteered
we followed the paddy wall to a drainage
ditch that took
us behind the north korean anti-tank
positions
the plan was simple to get right to the
rear of the sniper shoot the son of a
[ __ ]
and go back and finish my seas the ditch
had an
l-shaped turn we stopped just shy of it
where i inched forward to have a quick
peek three koreans manning a machine gun
were lying in the prone position about
10 feet away not looking our direction
i slipped back to wells whispering that
i'd take the first guy he'd take the
third and we'd double up on the gunner
in the middle
we stepped out of the ditch the north
koreans looked up but wells and i were
the last thing they ever saw
i knew they were dead they were so close
that i could hear the slugs
thumping home in their padded jackets we
jumped over them and continued on our
way
with wells covering my ass i came up
behind a little tree at the top of the
ditch
ideal concealment for a quick look see
after a few second scan i spotted the
sniper on the hill
he was in a bunker about a hundred yards
away on my left and i could clearly see
the side of his head
and his soviet sks rifle i ducked down
i didn't want to take a chance on
kentucky windage so i adjusted my
m1 rifle sights down four clicks and got
into a firing position
i had the sniper's head sitting right at
the top of my front sight
but just as i was about to squeeze the
trigger i heard machine gun slugs
snapping over my head
then the weapons report the weapons
report oh [ __ ] i thought
someone seen me for all i knew it could
have been one of our tankers the slugs
were coming from that direction
maybe they hadn't gotten the word that
we were out here so i started to go down
but as i went down i felt the top of my
head
explode i'd caught a slug
so what do we have here well we have
a potential blue on blue scenario i
guess we we don't know where that
round's coming from but it's coming from
the general position of his tanks
so how's that happening well the people
don't know where he is
how important is to know where each
other on the battlefield it's the most
important piece of information you have
what's a sea ration i mean i know it's
food you know what an mre is right yeah
so that's the old school mre
but they came in cans not in the plastic
pouches that the modern
mre comes in so they say it's like c
right is it the letter c
ration or it's s-e-a rational they write
with a c as just the legislator just the
but i don't know where the origination
of maybe it's canned rations
oh yeah that might be it i don't think
it's like uh these are meant for
naval vessels at the sea because they
because they they wouldn't use them out
there because
on ships they have kitchens big
refrigerators and kitchens and stuff
i'm sure we'll find out when this comes
out people will let us know
yeah canned i'm guessing canned that
makes sense
yeah but that doesn't necessarily mean
the truth yes
like most good wolfhounds i wasn't
wearing a helmet helmets were a pain in
the ass unless there was a lot of
artillery and mortar fire coming in in
which case
they became as essential as air the slug
ripped through my fur pile cap and
propelled me from the top of the ditch
as though i'd been
polaxed by paul bunyan
i don't know if i lost consciousness or
not but i do know
i was stunned with four alarm sirens
ringing in my ears
wells thought i was dead and took off
down the ditch i couldn't blame him
he thought he was all alone and behind
enemy lines meanwhile
i tried to focus on what had happened so
that sucks
by the time you get shot and you come
too you see your buddy
leaving you for dead and you can't even
blame him because you just got shot in
the head
blood really thick was pumping out of my
head
the first thing i did was ask myself my
name rank and serial number
david hackworth david haskell hackworth
sergeant
ra19242907
that's pretty funny he's he's been in
the military so like
institutionalized that the first thing
he asks is name ranking serial number of
himself
that's just beautiful
that came the automatic response which
made me decide that my head must still
be
okay even if my ass was the worst crack
ever
i started crawling down the ditch i had
to crawl because the north koreans on
the high ground
knew they had an intruder in their
midsts
i stayed low on the enemy's side slugs
were spraying the ditch fast and furious
but thumping up against the other wall i
crawled until i reached the machine gun
crew
wells and i had knocked off now i was
faced with a dilemma
if i jumped over them i'd become
exposed to the enemy fire coming from
the hill
if i crawled over them one of them might
still be alive
and the longer i looked the more my
confused head
convinced me to see that one of them was
alive
and he'd kill me i couldn't shoot them
because
when i got hit i dropped my rifle
so i just stared at them like a dumb
recruit wondering what to do
i pulled my trench knife out of my boot
very very carefully i crawled over one
of them waiting for him to move
i crawled over the next one waiting for
him to move then i crawled over the
third guy the same way and slipped on
like a snake down the ditch
until it was high enough for me to
crouch then high enough for me to stand
up and run
the whole time i was singing
whoever said there aren't any atheists
on the battlefield was dead right
often when we'd be sitting around our
little fires
one of the guys in the platoon would
play his guitar and we would sing
the songs were all religious ones like
down by the riverside
where we'd be laying down our swords and
shields or
please dear jesus hear my plea just a
little closer walk with thee
but there were also songs of great
comradeship
and a most magic feeling would always
pour out when we sang
a feeling that third platoon our platoon
was our family our whole life
and somehow between god and our brothers
we were going to make it through
so as i pounded down this ditch
i was singing just a closer walk with
thee
with deep feeling ella fitzgerald look
out
to my mind i was really talking to god
i was talking to the man
so i'm singing and running bloods
pouring out of my head
and then i remembered i didn't have my
rifle
what a rotten example i had set
good ncos don't screw up like that
only a dumb [ __ ] of a soldier loses his
rifle
so i stopped singing and started chewing
my ass as i ran down that ditch
maybe it was because i was thinking
about my lack of professionalism
maybe it was just second nature thing
from my training
or maybe it was a sixth sense i don't
know
but seconds before i was home free just
a few feet more i told myself
just around the corner i stopped
hey third platoon it's hackworth i
shouted
i'm coming in
then i turned the corner i found myself
looking down the throat of corporal
wesley morgan's mean looking browning
automatic rifle man
you were so loud coming down that ditch
i thought at least a platoon of gooks
was on the march
wells told me you got it if you hadn't
called out
i would have mowed you down so we have
another uh
potential blue on blue scenario
there
and you know
i'm calling out all these little
examples in this book and this book is
just
it it just it just it just filled with
them
it's filled with them over and over
again and
we'll get into more of it um
this is a long book we could i could
talk about this book
forever i think i've read it so many
times and every time i read it i find
something new something different
you know i've got here's my here's my
original copy this is the first copy i
ever got right here
this old one it's all beat up um
i i sent tim ferriss a copy and
he sent me a note back and he said i
said hey here's you know here's about
face this is the book i mentioned
and i sent him like an old hardcover
because i have a bunch of copies and
i've got a bunch of signed copies
and he he like felt bad
because it was a it was an older looking
book he's like wait a second is this
like because we had talked about it even
off the podcast
he goes wait a second is this like the
book that you had in iraq and i go no no
no it's just the normal it's just a copy
but it's an older copy um
yeah there's just so many lessons and
and like i said the book is 830 pages
long
with small writing
and also what's cool about it is you can
open it up you don't have to read the
whole thing you can open up anywhere you
can start reading if you know the
general story
you can start reading it anywhere and
that's that makes it
beneficial and actually leif was telling
me the other day and i remember doing
this once life was telling me
he would like you know we'd be talking
about something i have it down in the
tactical operations like sitting on my
deck
desk and you know there'd be some
something in there i'd read it to him
you know be like hey listen to this
you know him and his assistant platoon
commander whatever i'd read it to him
and you know say what does that remind
you of and it'd be some situation the
exact situation that
we were going through you know and
so yeah even leif remembers how much i
relied on this book
but you know
the other thing about this book i think
is that this book started to get me to
see the way
in all things it was the first book
where i started
i i bet you could do a good video
of like layering things
on like all the little examples i
pointed out
can you imagine those words like high
ground starting to really like
come like seeing it and seeing like oh
that's
cover that's important high ground
that's important
you know people doing things leading
from the front like all those things
starting to just
sort of appear as their level of
importance and the connectivity to what
i was going through and what i would see
so it's like this book even though i had
already been to college
and i have to give credit to when i was
when i had when i was when i studied
shakespeare in college
you know i was an english major so i had
to study shakespeare
and when we covered henry v on podcast
15 i was talking about the fact that
you don't you you have to really read
shakespeare you have to look up the
words you don't know you have to
you have to decipher it this and so that
was
one level of my ability to comprehend
what i was reading
but this was like the next level of
of realizing that what you're reading
can be overlaid and it can be
that you can it can add context and it
can be instituted into your own context
of your own experience
yeah like kind of like the bible almost
yeah you know like
you'll tell a story and then the like
the story
the significance the story is like the
lesson right and then so yeah if you
approach the book
that it is this it is i'm reading this
book for the lesson
like as it applies to me today you know
so you can kind of look to it for
guidance
yeah other look i mean we've covered
the first the podcast the books that we
covered on this podcast
a lot of those books i read but way
before we started the podcast
but like when i would read those books i
would basically be reading
a quote cool war story right
this was the first book where i started
going wait a second
i see the connection i see
the connection not just like all of a
sudden i started drawing
those same connections in all these
other books that i would read
but it started with this one which is
and i don't know why
maybe it's because it's long and maybe
it's because it rep
it repeats those same lessons over and
over again
but yeah i got to it's really the first
time i got to utilize
someone else's knowledge in a way to
help me not just to help my
knowledge but really to add to my own
experience
and this book uh this book did it for me
so
um we'll cover more of it
we'll cover more in the future but
is that out this is out this is
available we have it on the website
as you know
yeah hey there are there are two
versions yeah so there's the old
there's the old version and you actually
have to go specifically and we'll put
the link
yeah you have to go specifically to the
new version of it
to get the the one that has that forward
that i read
um yeah if you want to check out this
book and yeah that's the thing don't be
intimidated because it's 834 pages
because you can read it
three pages at a time that's the other
thing that's cool it's not like a
book where you've got to read 20 pages
to be like get something out of it you
can read four pages of this
yeah then you'll get something out of it
yeah yeah some and
yeah some books are cool like that where
and you you can kind of sp
especially if you just know the general
story where you right you open up
wherever and you're like okay and you
can get the
you know like some of them you're like
oh shoot i shouldn't read this part
because not only will it might it might
not make sense but i
you know you kind of should read the
beginning first you know otherwise
whether it be spoilers or whatever and
you know what else will we'll go into at
some point
you know i always on this podcast the
few times that i've read from this book
i'm only i only talk about the war part
but there's massive sections of his
career
between the korean war and the vietnam
war where he was
he was a soldier in a peacetime
environment so
what he was doing was he was doing
maneuvering he was building
relationships he was doing all these
things all these leadership things that
you have to do as a leader
in order to build relationships and make
good decisions and know when to bet like
all that stuff so it's not
it's not all war even though a lot of it
is
but he covers all these different
dynamics of human
relationships and human nature and it's
just
[Music]
it's just good so i i like i said i'm
honored i got to write the forward
i'm honored i've been able to share this
book with a bunch of people
so hack
thank you thank you for the knowledge
and passing it on and with that um
echo speaking of knowledge do you have
any knowledge you want to share with us
sure hell yeah well we are on the path
this is how to stay on the path
this whole deal okay we'll we'll discuss
it how about that
so we're working out we are are you
injured right now
no no i got some uh i got some
small cuts but i don't really consider
those injuries small
scrapes caught to what not from branches
no the reef the re oh yeah okay there's
been some waves
here in southern california basically
to your reference there i was as we know
hunting
in the wilderness in the wilderness in
the wild and while i was hunting i
actually didn't receive any
no no cuts no scrapes you know there's
always that possibility especially
you know when it's dark and you can fall
sure but
no and and you don't wear nods night
vision goggles obviously
no typically right that's not a typical
so it's a little
it's a little easier to fall once it
gets dark uh where were you
i was in utah mm-hmm so what what do we
do
what it's cold there it's cold or warm
uh regularly
whatever the temperature was absolutely
one
it was warm it was a little too warm it
was it was comfortable i was gonna say
absolutely comfortable
but the problem is it's too warm it
needs to be colder for the type of hunt
that i was doing oh cause it was like
art like
you guys are traveling right now no it's
just
the animals elk they like it to be
colder and they're more active when it's
colder okay
so when it's hot they kind of sleep and
it's harder to find them
and you're trekking through the
mountains on a certain course
or is it like the kind you're just
looking for elk
you're looking for elk and what's have
you ever seen an elk
bugle before so elk do something called
bugling which is a completely
animalistic dinosaur crazy screeching
howling noise and they go nuts doing it
and so you hear that and then you try
and go to it
except for the crazy thing is they're
they're so fast
yeah it's they're they're just the way
they move
through the wilderness yeah you you know
when you run hills
sure hell yeah hills and you know let's
say you're running up a decent hill
like i don't care who you are when you
sprint up a hill
you're going to be tired yeah but an elk
does not occur
[Music]
they're just they're going up hills as
if you're dude just walking across this
yeah sidewalk yeah not even breathing
hard at the top
the uh you know when you watch
national geographic or something like
this where you see these animals and
you know like yeah you see the obvious
big ones the
elephant and the buffalo you're like oh
yeah that's big but
man a wild animal even if it's kind of
the smaller like i'm quiet there's these
little goats
right these goats that cruise on the
mountains and stuff and from far away
like oh look at that goat but you start
to get
i mean i haven't been right up to one a
wild one but as you
kind of can see them closer you're like
man that thing's kind of intimidating
just how like
capable it is you know like so these
elks like they get kind of big
right oh yeah like it's not like a
little deer like on like you know when
you watch like bambi these deers are
just so
so like fragile these things ain't bad
and they fight each other they fight
each other
and they just throw down yeah it's crazy
to watch
it's great and and you know it's uh it's
an awesome experience
for sure it's just like you know how
like when you think of like
oh you know these people or whatever
kids they're like yeah i'm a tiger
or i'm a lion and it's like yeah obvious
you know lions are ferocious
sure but in real life like
a wild animal like an elk for example
bro when you go up to it you're like
bro that thing is ferocious you know
like you don't realize that when you see
it on a youtube video or something like
that every once in a while maybe like if
they're
you know involved in certain actions but
well you know how strong
like let's say a lizard like you know
when you grab a lizard
or just a small animal like how strong a
small animal is
yeah compared to a human right for like
pound-for-pound
yeah so then you think what's that like
when this thing weighs 800 pounds you
know
because they're exponentially stronger
than
weak humans yeah let's face it we're
just weak
as a as a animal yeah we're
just kind of pathetic as an animal
you know compared to what the average
elk
can sprint up a hill like it's nothing
like it's nothing and by the way it can
ram its freaking
head into stuff and they kill each other
they kill each other we saw we saw
bodies on the ground
elk bodies on the ground from fights
yeah
and the other elk aren't super concerned
about it because this is kind of a thing
you know you're gonna get there's gonna
be some casualties out there
that's that's life in these scenarios
that's death
and what you guys are out there what no
cell phone no nothing or yet service or
what like what kind
very limited service okay spotty yeah i
mean very
like we there was one little hill we'd
go over yeah and at the top
you might catch a bar yeah you know i'd
get 78 texts
yeah and then i'd just look at him and
go i'm just gonna keep walking until my
service goes away
yeah i uh i got um or i sent you a
picture
of something and you know how like when
you send a picture somebody will say
delivered yeah you know
it didn't say delivery for like a long
time like later that day i looked in
yeah cause i went over the top of that
hill chasing an elk somewhere but
awesome experience
good man well no help this evening i
know yep empty handed i was gonna say
awesome experiences but i
i also have to add empty-handed but uh
knock on tv yep right i follow them yep
and there was a picture early on yep of
an elk like close yeah what happened
with that
well so where we are hunting you have to
take elk that are of a certain age
and if they're not old enough you don't
shoot them yeah
and so i ran into quite a few elk like
that it was very oh it was very unlucky
um and look look is it okay am i saying
i
i just didn't get lucky i'm telling you
um i we i tried my hardest man
so you know i tried my hardest man we
spent a lot of time out there
we did everything we could uh dudley's
an amazing hunter
we had a guide with us amazing hunter
and
you know the scenario that you're put
into is as good of a scenario as you can
get
really for for elk hunting but
it's still not a guarantee man and
we spent you know many many many hours
and hiked very
far and wide as long as we could you
know to try and get it done
and it doesn't happen so the
you know what you what you get out of i
got a lot of experience out of it
um obviously hanging out with a bunch of
great guys up there just a bunch of
great people
and so that's that's awesome but it's
also humbling you know
it's humbling you don't always win man
and if it bums you out that you don't
win
find a different thing to do because
you're not always going to win it's like
jiu jitsu in that way
like if you just want to win in jiu
jitsu you don't train because you're not
just going to win
you know it's not going to happen yeah
in fact you kind of
i mean especially the whole journey you
lose
especially on your way up you're losing
way more than you're winning
in any capacity it's like jiu-jitsu oh
yeah for sure and i feel like in this
elk scenario too where
man it's kind of like if you get one
that's like
that's like a big deal you know it's
it's a huge deal yeah
it's a huge deal like you not getting
one and i don't even know about elk
hunting
by the way but you not getting one i
wasn't like oh that's surprising i was
like well that makes sense to me
you know you can go for weeks yeah and
and there's
the scenario that i'm hunting in is a
very it's the best scenario you can put
into
a lot most people that hunt are going
out what they call a public land hunt
where you're just going out in the wild
yes i'm in a more
controlled environment
where there's uh where there's uh
they have a better sense of of the
number of elk that are there
and that's why it's controlled like that
so but
like i said hey even with all those
things stacked in my favor it ain't no
guarantee
you know it ain't no guarantee and i'm
living proof of that
because we tried man we tried thin i
appreciate everyone's help you know that
you know i mean just the training and
learning how to shoot
um just good just good people
trying to trying to make it happen but
yeah it's yeah and that's
like a crazy feeling too about when i
was young i used to make slingshots
mm-hmm
you cut the guava tree the why part for
sure
you cut you i used to skin it and
sand it over it make it look cool but
what would you write on there terminator
9.
so uh what was that weapon you used in
some video with a spreader
spreader yeah yeah you probably did you
write spread
anyway you put uh
made out of yeah the guava tree and then
you cut it then you put
um surgical tubing you know there's
different oh bro
i mean i made
anyway so you go out and you're trying
to
like hunt little birds and stuff right
and it's like bro it's like kind of hard
it's not you don't just you're not just
whacking birds all day like you're
missing pretty much so when you get one
it's like a huge huge deal so i kind of
understand
but the elks yeah same thing
dude exact same thing exact same thing
anyway so you're not injured that's good
you know some cuts some bruises
that's good yep i'm saying injuries i
fee and
injuries all part of the game for sure
you have to contend with injuries yes
yeah one hundred percent
they're all in place yeah let me say i
hate to say this maybe you can
correct me if you think i'm wrong but i
would go so far as to say
if you're getting zero injuries you
might
need to step it up a little bit right
i'm not saying you want to get injured
right i hate being injured yes i hate
being injured
yeah but the only way to completely
avoid injury
is playing video games which even that i
guess you could get carpal
tunnel syndrome or something purple
tunnel i think is like more of a typing
thing you're like what do you call this
pronated supinated
right greg train yeah yeah greg
whenever he's explaining moves he's
using his medical terms
anatomical positions yeah yeah all right
so what are you getting at bro
i might well have long side well it
wasn't necessarily getting at anything
i'm just trying to re-like
visit kind of where we all are you know
but you make a good point
like where yeah you're not of course
you're not saying i don't think
it can be i'm sure it can be but um it
i'm not interpreting it as like yes you
should
pursue getting injured and that's when
you know you're hardcore no it's not
that
but with most exercise most most
worth it exercise is going to come with
an element of risk
yes so whether you're pushing hard
whether you're going through
dynamic terrain yeah whether you and
which can be
a few different things whether it be jiu
jitsu even like long distance outdoor
running and stuff like this is like this
is all for real stuff
cliff client you know all this stuff so
yes well you know
that's not my jam obviously i don't know
what's called cliff what is it called
it's just called rock climbing rock
climbing yeah okay cliff climbing
i mean they're technically right they
are rocks and they are a cliff
yeah we're good either way anyway as we
get older
or slingshot hunting
very similar to elk hunting yeah
sometimes same thing pretty much
yes very very similar uh well
on our way through this path whatever it
may be exercise wise we do need
supplementation
sometimes not just not just exercise but
also cognitively
sometimes we want supplementation as
well oh yeah to to
to reap full benefits of that the path
provides yes i agree so let's talk about
choco fuel
gotcha supplementation all day physical
weight okay so we stop
start with the foundation the structure
doesn't mean as much in my experience
anyway
i've only lived one life of course so
far
early on in life versus later on late in
life it seems like the structure
kind of signifies more significant in my
experience
you don't worry about your joints you
know your back can highlight people like
when you get when you get um
like trainers they'll be like hey you
need to start with your core right you
see what i'm saying
yeah because your core is where your
base and all this stuff brad let's face
it when you're young you're like core
boy
bro what are you even talking about
you're just thinking arms get on the
biceps
see what's up with that [ __ ] yeah no
one's doing core max out anyway
but as you grow older you understand so
is that a thing core max outs
even to make fun of it because i've
never heard that before but it's very
funny
oh okay like hey let's do some core max
outs
what do you max yeah i don't know yeah i
don't know i just made it up
but it sounded correct and given the
circumstances
nonetheless the point is joints joint
warfare this is what
okay jocko joint warfare this is
supplementation for your joints keep
them in
in check in check in the game
start at the foundation dudley had a
little knee
tweak while we were up in the mountains
and he
was just dosing joint warfare yeah and
he was
in he was in a he was in like an echo
charles situation where he didn't have
it
and then he went back on it and his knee
was just he was able to power through
you know what bursitis is yes okay so i
get
i've had it before yeah okay i've had
bursitis on my shoulder and my
heel yeah my heel it's weird
so i get bursitis now
when because i didn't do this before i
do deep squats
barefoot for some reason i get bursitis
in my heel
just genetic weakness really it's
possible
nonetheless when these things happen i
have this
weird like confidence like it'll happen
like i'll do it then the next day like
i'll be walking down the stairs like oh
man like it it feels like
almost like a shark so it's a weird very
distinct feeling in your hair
but i always have this weird like
subconscious almost
feeling that it's like oh this is going
to be gone immediately even though it's
like
really bad so you know when you have
injury then you have
full recovery that time to me just feels
like in my brain
i'm so confident that that time is going
to be like almost no time because the
next day
because the joint warfare because you're
on the joint yeah that's how it feels
and the krill oil really
right yeah the combo 100 so sure enough
next day it's still sore just as sore
i'm like frick this is like this might
be something serious you know like it
might be bad
the next day after that pretty much gone
yeah it's like it just it's like it
decides to just
be i just feel like you know it's one of
those one of those deals
nonetheless so drug warfare krill oil
discipline
discipline go yes well let's
start with mark though so from the front
like consider the foundation and then
you start to go
up you got to build you got to build you
see insane
so you can be doing curls shoulder press
lat raises building up the upper body
right won't mean nothing why does that
get a whisper
it won't mean anything if your joints
are jammed up so you got to take care so
now go up now when you're doing the
bench
when you're doing that in your case dead
lift whatever you do
deep squats all day you're gonna need
the protein supplementation
for rebuilding that's when you implement
the mulch
i had mulk with me on my trip and like
we said i stayed one night at a hotel up
they're heading up there
roughing it up hotel city awesome
good day you know they got the little
well here's the thing they got the
little travel
samples yeah yeah you brought them those
things are awesome yeah
you know in an airport you can't bring
fluid through
so you just walk through get yourself a
little milk with your mulch
pouch and they'll probably break it out
yeah
yeah yeah actually that is a good
because i have a bunch of those
the the little packs i think they're
like from the musters and stuff and you
know pikachu
sent them to me oh okay i don't bust
into that at home yeah that's just like
on the road yeah that's good man it's
good move nonetheless it's
there for a long time i'm trying to
explain it to you you keep you know
trying to make me
elaborate i'm going to be doing it okay
so see if you can see if you can
go these these are things that i feel
are beneficial to know
if you see it as in its entirety as a
system it seems like
i'm trying to stay quiet but now you're
getting crazy there you go okay
so you really okay your joints are taken
care of ready
all good your muscles boom you work them
break them down and rebuild them
mulch supplemental protein in the form
of a dessert
all good working milk tube by the way so
if your kids you need general protein
and they like you know the dessert
scenario as well so that's available
then your body all good
all degenerating regenerating bigger all
good structure foundation all good
now you need the mind your mind keep you
mentally in the game
boom that's where the discipline comes
in it's insane discipline discipline go
uh cans powder whatever you like that's
your choice that part is on you
i can't give accurate specific guidance
on what's
uh implementation methodology
fair enough nonetheless if you're into
the energy drink scenario get the cans
yeah actually yeah if you're into the
energy drink
scenario as you just put it yeah
that's not good if you're into normal
energy drink scenarios that's not good
because those things are not good for
you
yes and i know it might sound crazy but
discipline go in a can
is good for you yeah it is good for you
yeah so there's no sugar in there
there's vitamins in there there's
caffeine 95 milligrams
grams of caffeine which is not some
crazy
you know run around there's some name
for dude like this
but anyways you know that dude yes sir
yeah we do
this isn't that this is like a mic
it's it's it's just it's just it's good
for you yeah so
and okay so i went kind of deep like
okay so i've been talking to pete
and brian recently there was so i you
know you kind of go deep in these rabbit
holes like okay like other
so apparently other energy drinks do a
lot of wonky stuff with their and it's
and it's
wonky meaning like they advertise this
but then meanwhile they're doing a lot
of this other stuff that they sort of
omit when they advertise you know so you
just
you kind of get maybe more than you've
you bargained for something in a bad way
in a bad way so and
i wound up watching this video it was a
comedy video for sure it was called like
a lot of people make this kind of video
like if energy drink advertiser
to advertisers were honest i'm the guy
and it's like this official guy and he's
saying like
all this stuff he wasn't talking about
any specific energy drink
so he's i was like bro he's talking
about all this like poison
and stuff like this is what they do to
do this and it makes it this and this is
that so if when you're
consuming your energy drink of death
like saying all this stuff
i'm like dang bro like i don't even know
because i used to like energy drinks
yeah well you were working late at night
and everything
yeah lacking plus you were lacking
energy
but now i feel kind of be betrayed but
not anymore just blink oh boom all day
all healthy hundred percent
preservatives nope pasteurized
nonetheless get on that sugar nope monk
fruit no monk fruit no sugar
so yeah all good there it is and while
so while you're on the path
that's supplementation supplementation
methodology
perfection it's a perfect system anyway
you get all these stuff
all this stuff at origin maine.com or
at the vitamin shop if you're walking in
or if you're in florida or virginia
we got a little situation coming to the
wawa
stores we'll be there in october
yeah so the go get some so this is how
it goes
if you're in florida or virginia in the
morning you take the joint warfare
before you or depends on when you work
out before the workout on your way to
the gym if you're going to the gym
you stop at wawa you get the discipline
go
boom to the gym hit the gym smash the
gym really
smash it come home boom monk all day
you'll be on the path big time just
establish that routine
anyway all right back to origin origin
origin
origin origin main.com
also on there american-made stuff
straight up
jeans boots geese guards t-shirts
american-made stuff yeah which which may
not seem like a big deal
but it is a huge deal it's a huge deal
you know you know what the typical
business scenario
is hey cool let's start a brand
outsource it to some overseas place
yeah get the price as cheap as you can
take advantage of
of of slave labor basically
yeah and then we'll bring it back here
and we'll sell it for some incredible
markup and make a bunch of money and not
hire anybody because we're just going to
keep it all
yeah or you can do what we're doing yeah
build it here treat workers well
because they have awesome value
become self-sufficient as a country
maintain knowledge ancient knowledge
which is almost lost almost lost
we got it yeah you know that that that
situation when the ball is about to go
out of bounds that someone
gets there just in time that's what
origin is doing
just in time yeah to save the knowledge
yep and and the big corporations you
know what they say
you cannot make this stuff here it's
impossible
no it's not it was done before we're
doing it now
watch me yeah and it's kind of you know
like
these like the jeans for example like
when you think about it like oh yeah the
designer jeans like
when you consider really what are you
paying for this it's like the whatever
the brand
but what do you like for real pain for
like what do you care about about those
those jeans you know sure the fit okay
that's good if that's a thing if that's
for real a thing
let's face it i've been thinking about
that whole aspect of designer jeans and
you know what these are designer jeans
they're designed for work they're
designed to last
they're designed to function properly in
all scenarios
so they are designer jeans they're
designed for work get some of that
all right there you go i think sign me
up
um yeah my favorite jeans hundred
percent also
jocko has a store it's called jocko
store and this is where you can get your
shirts while
while you're on this path you want to
represent discipline equals freedom good
got shirts hats hoodies new board shorts
by the way good
utility water jiu-jits
all that they're brand new anyway
uh some soda some irish oaks ranch soap
chocolate soap trooper soap oreo kids
soap all that stuff anyway yes
jacostore.com
if you like something get something you
can also listen to some podcasts that we
have including this one
you can subscribe to it and you can
you can leave a what do they say leave a
review leave a review
comment and like here's the thing
i would say okay so you jaco
willink you currently have the best
content as far as comments go so not
even necessarily on your okay so you did
the one the the
stuff for gq yeah the the movies or
whatever break down the breakdowns
and there was another one i think it
might have been your ted talk brochure
read those comments
bro it's like uh
like when when jocko was born the doctor
turned to his parents and said it's a
man you know like that kind of man it's
so
funny or when jaco left left for college
he told his father you're the man of the
house now
bro you're i'm reading these like
laughing out loud reading all these
comments oh man it's the best
nonetheless yes we have a youtube
channel uh so yes subscribe to that
too leave a comment if you want to if
you have one of those man i don't even
care if it's like kind of funny
but just just say those comments really
good yep
uh we also have other podcasts by the
way we have a podcast called the
unraveling which we are about to launch
on its own what feed
yeah so we have that the unraveling
giaco unraveling
look that up um we got more episodes
coming we're starting to get caught up
to where the episodes are a little bit
more
let's say current to what's happening in
the world right now we spent a lot of
time in iraq we've
we've so we're going so check those out
if you want to check those out
we got the grounded podcast which we
haven't done a long time although it
kind of seems like we just did one
as you tried to explain the methodology
for taking mulk which is fine
you know you know it's critical you know
we got to use decentralized command here
you
i got to let you run with it sometimes
it's all good warrior kid podcast i
haven't done one of those in a while as
well so
um sorry
straight up that's it yeah well there
you go
uh they're all good podcasts very
valuable but yes
maybe not quite as consistent as the
jungle podcast yeah and you know it
makes sense
anyway yes and i mentioned the youtube
channel we have youtube channel so yes
video version
all that stuff excerpts all good also
psychological warfare
if you need a boost from jocko telling
you the right thing to do
when you're about to do the wrong thing
aka skipper workout aka
eat donuts aka do do something that you
know you're not supposed to do you never
plan to do it
in fact you plan not to do it but a
moment of weakness is kind of
luring you in whatever you want
chocolate to tell you why you should or
shouldn't do something
boom there you go psychological warfare
uh don't forget about if you flip side
canvas flipsidecams.com
dakota meyer's company making stuff to
hang on your wall that is graphically
cool
i've got a bunch of books got this book
here called about face
i wasn't sure because it's a a reissue i
wasn't sure if there would be
an if this would be quote a first
a dish i just got my copies
and i found out that yes indeed what you
have with this book
this version of this is a first
a dish of this version you can see it
right there
above where it says library of congress
congress
there's a numbers one through ten and
when this is the first to dish which
means the one is there
oh yeah after the first dish is gone you
won't see that one anymore
that's a problem so you'll be on second
a dish which
pretty much is an awful place to be
terrible brutal
brutal what's the uh what's the the
actual
like name now you know how this is
called about face
there's no change to it all it says is
is forward by
docker willing okay so there's no other
change to it i mean the cover the cover
is also a little bit different
uh yeah it's actually i guess a lot
different so
well it's not a lot different there's a
helmet it's a little bit different uh so
yeah and we'll link it
link it to the the right one i've been
signing about faces
for a long time like people bring me in
about face and i don't sign them
so um that's pretty cool and now i get
to sign one that
is even just a little bit cooler
basically
and now you can get it first it's hard
to get a first a dish of the original
book yeah now you can get a first
edition of
the reissue the relaunch anyways check
it out uh don't forget about the code
written by me dave burke sarah armstrong
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual
all the answers are in there by the way
all the answers are in there
so so check that one out we got way of
the warrior kid one two and three we got
mikey and the dragons we got this
clinical freedom field manual we got
extreme ownership and we got the
dichotomy of leadership
all kinds of books if you won't like
what i talk about here you can get more
you can get you can get the books and
read about it and and and
overlay and understand these things in a
much deeper way
we also have echelon front which is my
leadership consultancy where we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelonfront.com for details on that we
got ef online
which is me talking answering questions
got the rest of the echelon front team
there
we're doing live things we got a forum
we got
leadership primer and immediate action
drills all kinds of stuff
to help you as a leader we got the
muster which is our
leadership event there's only one
in 2020 duda the covid virus
it's gonna be in dallas texas december
third and fourth go to
extremeownership.com for details now
listen
we've done every one of these that we've
done is sold out we were gonna do two
earlier this year they both got
cancelled because of covid
and so people have transferred their
tickets over to that one so this one's
going to sell out
plus we it looks like we might have to
have less seating depending on the covet
scenario
so if you want to come come and sign up
now
and of course we have ef overwatch
executive leadership for your company
that understand the principles that
we're talking about
people leaving the military whether
retired they're getting out
these are experienced leaders that can
come help you and your company go to
efoverwatch.com
and if you want to help service members
active and retired their families their
gold star families around the world and
check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization
called america's mighty warriors go to
america's mightywarriors.org to donate
or get involved
and if you need to hear more of my
over burdened oration
or you feel you need to absorb more of
echo's unbridled banter then you can
find us
on the interwebs on twitter
on instagram which is what echo calls
the gram
and facebook echo is that echo charles
and i am at
jocko willink and thanks to
to colonel david hackworth for writing
this book
but more important thanks to colonel
hackworth for his service and sacrifice
and for his dedication to
our country and to his soldiers and a
dedication that
never wavered
and the rest of the military personnel
that are listening active duty retired
veterans
thank you for your dedication as well
with a special dedication
from hack
to all the dough boys the ground
pounders the grunts
the american infantry man past present
and future thanks to all of you
and to the police and law enforcement
and the firefighters and paramedics and
emts and dispatchers and correctional
officers and border patrol and secret
service and all the other first
responders
thank you for your level of dedication
that you also show
to keep us safe here at home and to
everyone else out there
let's remember that lesson from henry c
de boer who died on that frozen piece
of korea on february 6
1951 the lesson is if you're taking
care of yourself if you're making
yourself
the priority then you're a coward
but if you take care of others
if you step up and do the right things
for the right reasons if you put the
needs of
others above yourself you will
be a hero
so go and be heroic
until next time this is echo and jocko
out